déconfinement on l'attendait cette
nouvelle ce calendrier et c'est un mot
que tout le monde espérait entendre
jours et c'est arrivé aujourd'hui on y
est il peut commencer mais vous avez
entendu à l'instant le provenance du 'mo
lo' dans quelques instants le dr luc
boileau répond le directeur national de
santé publique répond à mes questions
mais écoutons encore une fois le premier
ministre beaucoup de québécois sont
tannés sont tannés des consignes ça fait
22 mois je comprends aussi que beaucoup
de québécois que ça commence à affecter
leur santé mentale donc on a convenu
avec la santé publique ne vous annoncer
aujourd'hui quelques petits
assouplissement mais l'idée c'est d'y
aller graduellement
prudemment donc d'y aller tranquillement
comme on dit en québécois la fouille
aller mollo donc si vous aviez un mot
retenu aujourd'hui c'est le mot mollo
faut y aller mollo
je pense qu'on a eu comprimé résumons
ces mesures qui se décline en deux
phases d'abord pour le lundi 31 janvier
ce sera l'ouverture des salles à manger
des restaurants à la moitié de leurs
capacités les rassemblements privés
seront autorisés à quatre personnes ça
peut être de quatre adresses différentes
aux deux bulles familiales sont inclus
les enfants ça peut être plus que 4
évidemment le nom de visiteur passera à
deux par jour en sièges et celle des et
à 4 dans les résidences privées pour
aînés les rpa les jeunes et les
étudiants pourront reprendre les sports
en milieu scolaire l'entraînement une
semaine plus tard le 7 février les
salles de spectacle les cinémas et les
lieux de culte pourront rouvrir les jim
les spas et le sport pour adultes
devront attendre mon invité le directeur
national de santé publique le dr luc
boileau bonsoir docteur boileau
bienvenue à 24,60 on est heureux de
recevoir
alors mollo je pense qu'on sait tous que
ça veut dire me promener sans invoquer
la santé mentale du tt ii du risque de
perdre l'adhésion 7 acceptabilité
sociale ou du tt de la grande qui se
sentiraient ce qu'on aurait eu ce même
calendrier aujourd'hui
je pense que oui parce que les mesures
que nous prenons de dévolution de sept
ans des milieux et de son impact sur le
système de santé nous laisse clairement
croire qu' on est dans une
pente qui est descendant l'escalier
abruptement descendante nos éminents
plan de 120 oui est-ce qu'on doit être
prudent oui c'est ce qui est fait en ce
moment mais on avait besoin aussi de
maintenir comme vous le dites l'adhésion
des communautés à toutes ces mesures
mais aussi on avait besoin de donner un
rythme qui nous permet de revenir dans
une position normale alors c'est
progressif c'est simplement pour
compléter avec les annonces
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est comme deux
premiers ministres 10 graduelle prudent
et heures en mairie ouais c'est parce
que le fameux choc du 30 décembre car
nous prive les gens par surprise et
finalement il
la montée des cas de micron et le fait
que les gens en train de dire donner 90%
ou presque de vacciner on fait tout ça
pour d'autres alors que les
hospitalisations augmenté que les décès
sont encore élevés aujourd'hui cette
décision nous apporte quand même des
chiffres c'était très peu différent dans
le nombre de cas par rapport à la
semaine dernière
qu'est-ce qui fait la tirah pull
délestages au niveau 4 est toujours en
cours qu'est-ce qui a fait que vraiment
on pouvait s'entendre sur ces mesures là
aujourd'hui en fait le moins haut que la
semaine dernière on essaie la vague de
coop les cras défection au réellement
baissé sinon la réponse les chiffres et
de mon employeur désolé mais quand même
on n'a pas vraiment le test vous dites
bien mais en même temps la courbe au
niveau des espèces distance est parce qu
moins que ces colloques pour - depuis
probablement autour du 6 au 7 janvier en
même temps lorsqu'on regarde l'évolution
des hospitalisations on le sait qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de spécialisation vif
faut quand même savoir qui est à peu
près la moitié sont des hospitalisations
pour la cause et demi en à l'autre
moitié de ses expositions par des gens
qui viennent la communauté en europe 1
qu'il a crevé d'où il développe avec le
preneur oui qui sont donc comme vous
dites avec la copie donc c'est pas
exactement la même chose mignonne pente
qui dessert les données même de 2 ce
soir on que ça continue et c'est
rassurant pour ça et en même temps il ya
eu une nouvelle arme quitter notre porte
et damman il y en a une qui est doha qui
est à notre portée seulement c'est la
vaccination et on encourage tout le
monde qui a la chance de bénéficier de
soda l'isf avec ce n'est en particulier
les gens qui sont le service dont plus
de 50 à plus de 60 ans ça c'est un
masque de ces sites incontournables mais
aussi on a le pacs de vide qui est
arrivé qu'ils font en grande quantité
dans à peu près mais 500 doses par
semaine mais si on les utilise bien ça
pourrait nous aider à baisser les
risques d'hospitalisation alors armé de
cela on est capable de faire avancer la
société
proposera des éléments qui vont
faciliter la socialisation et d'autres
choses comme vous les avez des clips
parce que d'un côté vous devez
convaincre la vexation c'est la clé
c'est la porte de sortie assez la
lumière au bout du tunnel une expression
est encore des gens qui sont pas encore
convaincus de cela on verra
ensuite pour la
suite pour la vaccination parce qu'elle
est ce que vous trouvez que ça va trop
lentement pour la dose de rappel la
troisième dose on est à quoi 76%
oui mais en fait on est plus élevée
ctions dans lego qui sont préservés on
aurait frappé nos juristes sont
canadiennes en particulier l'ontario et
ça ça va bien mais ça va encore pensé
bien si on était capables d'à peine de
se rapprocher considérablement du 100 %
pour les personnes je dirais depuis 50
ans tant mieux entre 50 et 65
à 60 ans ça va mieux mais il faut
vraiment faire une poussée de ce coupé
d'eau et éviter les gens suivent parce
que quand vous dites c'est la clé votre
prudence semble dictée par aussi ce qui
se passe ailleurs dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui rien qu'en france il y
avait cinq cent mille nouveaux cas
trente mille hospitalisation puis 3000
ce qu'apple est en réanimation nous soit
êtes un truc qu'on ne donne souvent dit
que ce qui se passait là bas elle est
arrivée ici est-ce que ce qui arrive là
bas en ce moment vous nouveau directeur
par intérim de la santé publique ça vous
préoccupe et il faut garder ça à
l'esprit
en garde soit parfaitement l'esprit
ensuite réduit ce qui se passe dans
d'autres juridictions parce qu'on ne la
chance nous la chance certaine manière
des dégâts les deux peuples et une à
trois semaines selon les endroits alors
mais on n'a pas la même situation
d'avoir une situation du système de
soins qui et qui fragilise et on ne peut
pas le même nombre de lits on a tout
s'est mis ce dévouement qui est bien
vivant bien présent mais en même temps
une fatigue qui nous amène à perdre des
joueurs des fois et des infections qui
font en sorte qu'on perde et les
employés y en a plus et le qui ne sont
pas au travail parce qu'ils ont été en
contact ou épilogue malheureux soudas
coville ça va revenir sur graduellement
est ce qu'on regarde beaucoup c'est la
nac six nations et ça c'est majeur la
vaccination des groupes à risque c'est
seul déterminant numéro un de trop faut
qu'on se dit nommé d'ici le plus
important dans les autres juridictions
ils ont pas été aussi forts que nous
pour réduire la transmission et maisons
qui ont été prises au québec ont été un
très significative vous savez mais on
donnait aussi des résultats importants
ont signé à descendre simplement à peu
près une semaine et demie après et puis
ça nous permet aujourd'hui de réouvrir
mais il faut continuer avec jean venir
avec le détail de certaines mesures
aujourd'hui mais avant j'aimerais me
dire quand on nous dise si les mesures
sanitaires marchait on le saurait il ya
tellement de corps que ça prouve que ça
marche pas qu'est ce que vous dites
enfin dans leur écoute et oui le décor
c'est bien évident que plus de 80 de
deux micros c'est un la même maladie le
soin virus vous avez d'autres invités
dans les années récentes qui vous le
dise de c'est un virus qui une
contagieuse d'aimer extrême et qui donne
moins d'effets sur la santé mais qui
donne quand même des effets très lo est
morte stade immortel pour un certain
nombre malheureusement alors on se
retrouve la variole il ya des gens qui
décèdent on ne peut pas plus de décès
ici au québec qu'ailleurs ceux ci il ya
des comparaisons chiffres de des
fonctions très malheureuse parce qu'on a
un système de captation des décès bien
plus généreux que ce qu'on trouve chez
nos voisins mais même en ontario alors
on fait pas un prix exagéré quant aux on
sait que nous ici on ne peut pas tout le
système de soins dans les compétences de
et les capacités dont le nombre de lits
pour absorber ce dense pour ça qu'il
faut continuer avec prudence mais c'est
sur la vaccination oui le pacs de vie et
se met la prudence pour ceux qui
décideraient malheureusement ce serait
tout un peu compliqué à comprendre mais
malheureusement pas se faire vacciner
réseauteur s'il vous plaît restez
prudents et paul temps d'augmenter vos
contacts rester prudent puis ceux qui
pensent en fin de semaine des bombes
envoyées vider notre ami nos voisins nos
parents
assurez-vous que sont vaccinés dont elle
savait déchire
d'acteurs boileau j'ai abordé de la
cohérence de certaines mesures parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya des adam c'est
ce qu'on soulève aujourd'hui bon les
restaurants vont rouvrir les salles de
spectacle ça va être plus tard les gens
se demandent comment ça se fait qu'on
attend encore une semaine de plus sale
quand on voit dans une salle de
spectacle on est masqué on était si on
bouge pas on va au restaurant on enlève
le masque alors les gens s'interrogent
la tuer l'association hôtelière aussi
puisqu'elles étaient laissés pour compte
il va y avoir les lieux de culte vont
pouvoir reprendre les salles de
spectacle à 500 personnes m'ont interdit
toujours les réunions les congrès les
colocs c'est un moteur
connu mais très important elle est où la
cohérence parce que c'est ça que les
gens se disent pourquoi tu comprennes
pas mon milieu à moi comme les spas et
ils ont lancé un cri du coeur il ya sont
pas pires que les jeunes qui vont faire
du sport et respecte enfin les mesures
et à la cohérence c'est plusieurs
s'interrogent là dessus écoutez d'abord
stimulus très bonnes questions et madame
tussauds pour aider à comprendre c'est
ce qu'il faut c'est trouver un fil
conducteur qui lui permet d'augmenter
qui
construit et qui vaut visiblement
augmenté les compères vont augmenter le
risque de transmission et va générer
plus de coop plus de subtilisation acef
il faut choisir dans as de la gamme des
mesures qui sont proposées celles qui
peuvent bénéficier ou tirer un bénéfice
collectif de plus rapide possible pour
le plus de monde possible or les deux
fois se rencontrer chez soi avec des
amis de famille c'est quelque chose qui
touche tout le monde d'aller au resto sa
touche pas mal de monde pour tout le
monde mais sérieusement d'aller dans les
salles de spectacles décidément ça
touche une partie de la population mais
moins que pouvoir recevoir à la maison
voir les ennemis dont il fallait donner
des mécanismes qui sont cohérents avec
les dénominateurs les plus communs à
tout le monde alors avec ça en fait je
pense que la progression s explique
elle est lente vous avez raison et
progressive mais elle est dosé de
manière à ce qu'on puisse surveiller
l'évolution de notre système de santé
qui est très fragile quand vous le dis
en début de l'entrevue c'est très juste
ça s'améliore mais qu'avant car sur une
bonne vigilance du train et profitons de
ce qui est proposé et profitons-en
sainement c'est à dire moi mais allez
vous faire vacciner
en même temps sur la question des
congrès des spas etc et vous devez
convaincre votre communication doit
expliquer justement pourquoi ces gens là
qui ne sont pas des milieux d'éclosion
et je rattache à ça un article du devoir
de ce matin qui cite une étude allemande
qui met sur un pied restaurant et salles
de spectacles qui dit capote
surinfection dans tous ces lieux là ils
nous ont nous ont fait la différence on
les classe différemment donc c'est sa
nourrice est cette grande peut-être
n'ont eux c'est vous soulevez un bon
point mais on y met sur un pied
quasiment d'égalité de se dire les lis
les restaurants bien les salles de
spectacles sont mis à une semaine de
distance de ce programme parce que de
deux mois et on a commencé par qui était
le plus accessible de plus disponible
pour tous et les salles de spectacles de
les raisons les salles de spectacles
sont capables de le tenir une grande
rigueur sur la dalle je dirais l'hygiène
collective et les fêtes de vraiment
s'assurer que les gens ne soient pas
trop en contact mais vous savez quand
vous allez dans un spectacle vous allez
pas d'autre tout du temps pour
socialiser vous allez vous asseoir
premier spectacle très bien quand vous
avez l'occasion de rencontrer la famille
des amis du voisinage chez vous pendant
non je pense que c'est la meilleure
chose qui puisse faire aux points donc
c'est logique c'est correct c'est
calculé aussi comme reese mais en même
temps 20 crise que quelques lignes y
avait beaucoup d'incertitude et c'est
pour ça qu'il va falloir suivre comme il
faut l'impact de tout le système
aujourd'hui à -13% confort y est sonné
le point de presse seule indépendamment
du premier ministre cette façon pour
vous peut-être d'affirmer votre
indépendance pendant qu'ils
souhaiteraient plus pour garantir les
votre indépendance et les perceptions
sont toujours importants tu es là comme
sert la santé il ya le scientifique en
chef il aimerait vraiment qui est une
réforme de la fonction du directeur
national de la santé publique pour
garantir cette année pense le duo body
politic de pointe et de panser vos
décisions sont conditionnées par un
agenda politique
qu'est ce que vous dites est la première
des choses c'est que regarder le mot ça
fait deux semaines aujourd'hui que je
suis en hausse quand on m'a invité à
faire ce jeudi pdg de délit n'est ce qui
est un institut hautement scientifique
du québec résidé pendant votre produit
ce qu'il veut le lot et qui est
indépendant dans ses processus
scientifique et danser et vie alors moi
je réussis avec la même posture de cet
ennemi clair on lui a demandé pour ce
disque que vous pouvez ramener cet
espace scientifique eu à redire à vous
associer à tout l'espace scientifique
disponible au québec et pour ramener un
point de vue en toute indépendance c'est
comme ça je n'ai entendu c'est comme si
pour ça que j'ai accepté et c'est comme
ça que ça se fait en ce moment alors je
suis mon intention de changer et
humaines ainsi d'autres prétendent qui à
juste titre on réfléchit de dire on veut
changer la structure mais c'est quelque
chose qui peut se passer après nommé en
plein milieu d'une crise décidé de dire
on va changer des doigts puis faire en
sorte qu'ils soient élus par l'assemblée
nationale aux deux tiers sympathie que
je pense pas que ça se peut se passer
dans une urgence en faut pour juste
médecins n'ont allez bon wagon en bonne
place dans le fait d'être intérimaire
seulement à ce que ça fait nuit et cette
indépendance là je vous dirais que ça
prend max salah solidifie parce que
sincèrement je suis poli on ne change
pas un stade où est ce que je veux faire
une carrière les tu le sais je connais
bien tous et ce domaine de la santé de
la santé publique parce que je fais ma
carrière l'avenant puis ça fait pris sa
fille je pense que pendant trente ans ça
me rajeunit pas donc j'ai été nommé par
tous les ministres à brno donc je suis
pas positif du tout et puis beach
capable d'apporter la science au rendez
vous et ça se passe comme ça et je vous
avoue franchement pour sookie ci
s'interroge je pense que le ministre et
premier ministre est en fait tous les
joueurs au niveau central que les
administrateurs accueil s'entraîner et
le fut de me permettre parce que je vais
demander au début j'ai dit que je pense
faire une bonne idée que je puisse faire
des points de presse pour vraiment
expliquer comme il faut les différentes
décisions qui a été acceptée n'y a pas
de souci c'est juste que moi j'ai voulu
avoir un bébé pendant deux semaines ne
peut pas maîtriser tous les dossiers du
jour au lendemain de sa fête de sainte
gemme amiens 2 1 dès maintenant deux
semaines on va une confortable au caire
rencontré les journalistes et les gens
qui s'intéressent à poser des questions
souvent importantes pour bien comprendre
pipeau lancer encore plus le message je
voulais podim et la vaccination
on l'a dit beaucoup à cette émission
d'interviews écoutez merci beaucoup
d'avoir prétendu allez ce soir on vous
interviewer dans vos autres fonctions
pour les contenants doivent être reçus
ce soir pour clarifier les décisions
d'aujourd'hui merci a bientot bonne
soirée madame dessous merci beaucoup en
soirée à mm pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]